[Music]
this time we're trying to make you
forget
who you are
and where you came from
[Applause]
don't let it do that
dale
jeffrey thompson house manager
10 years of a long time let me show you
around with him dom's at hillary
let's go find you something fit for a
friend
what do you think i made you love
yo i'm fulfilled
i'm glad you're safe we'll talk later
yo is this really baby ashley you're a
long way from home mom oh dude how you
been
you know
thriving
i hope uh one day we can talk about why
you're really here
do you know why i'm here from philly
scrapping the ball court
got nasty
now some bad man from philly he wanted
to deal with you
why move mountains to get you here
so here's the story
came to bel air for a better education
simple
be patient
give this a real chance
we have a different set of rules here
okay
you want to do well just keep your head
down and follow my lead oh whoa whoa man
you know i'm a west philly wherever i go
yo king what's up man
no love
look around
these are my people
what that one steer clear
welcome to bel air
what the hell is my life yo chill out
bro
maybe will just doesn't cut out for this
why are we working so hard to save a boy
who doesn't want to be safe
because we don't quit
a real man takes responsibility for his
actions
a real man knows when to let go of his
pride and make the most out of a second
chance
be the will who charmed west philly with
his talent and swag let the music defuse
all attention
[Music]
get out my
there's no going back
[Music]
you